I'm in a room full of geniuses right now
you guys are telling me that you these
are the only artistic people you know
I'm listening to people you know who
still live at they mother's house and
still trying to figure it out I'm just
trying to spread that peace and love
when I was poor man and it's about these
cool vibes is about this inspiration
he's an American rapper record producer
director actor and model he's a member
of the hip hop group ASAP mob in 2011 he
released his debut mixtape and signed a
two-year three million dollar record
deal with RCA he's ASAP rocky and here's
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well also as you are
writing something down it's much more
likely to stick in your head to enjoy
and you know not just getting to my
hip-hop form but that's just what it is
okay and I'm just trying to set the bar
that you could do you want to do because
the world is yours
disregard through a lot of ladies
walking past a lady you can do whatever
you want the world is yours and I'm
telling the young cast our generation
don't discriminate against anybody
because we're all one generation and
that's some important you know I mean
who would throw the ghetto kid would go
teach her French braids from the hood
will be in Vogue and GQ on the same
month in the same one at the same time
about the same who would have ever
thought Interview magazine when they did
an eight page spread who would ever
thought complex magazine a cover with a
game designer Jeremy Scott witching was
an idol of mine because I admired his
fashion and I admired his art since late
teen who would have thought I would have
did that you know why because I didn't
let the negativity hold me back and
that's what's holding out back
negativity man straight up don't give
nobody say dude feels right to you
you know who you are do you know who you
are and be you and I'm me I'm happy
being me feel good to be me right now
man straight up the question was when
you started first knew that you had that
moment that that confidence when you
felt it when I was poor man you know
it's just like I don't think confidence
is something that you could buy
something that's better than you you
know and some people gaining with
success that's just like the icing on
the cake but you're poor man with
confidence is and stop whoo-hoo almost
invincible why do you like this idea of
not being ordinary
it's just I just take it you know it is
what it is I come to terms I'm not into
now I've realized you know that I'm not
ordinary ain't nothing ordinary about me
from my looks from the way I think from
what decisions I've made
there's nothing ordinary my lifestyle in
ordinary so I accepted it if it means
that me being an ordinary is outside of
it it's my house I didn't call me what
you will
I'm cozy I'm chilling I'm happy to be
from all uptown I'm saying that's about
it I look at you like what do you mean
it's just like you know well I look at
it like you should let the people choose
it's a day and age where everything is
optional you know anything you need is
that this is at our fingertips a click
of a button yeah hear what I'm saying so
you should let the fans pick what they
want as a single you know why should we
why should we drive like songs and
program them into radio just drive it
into the heads I mean I think you should
pick what people like right give it so
by giving the albumen I got a single he
got a single cuz that's what this is I
think each song I mean as a whole it
makes sense they complement each other
it's like for me I wanted to try to
create a masterpiece just as much as
possible the way I knew but I feel like
each of them like singly individually
they stand on their own legs and I think
that a lot of individual people are
gonna be like well you know this one
really spoke to me but this one is cool
you know I don't really get that that's
what I wanted I didn't expect I didn't
want to make everyone try to like
everything is just I wanted to make art
and hope everyone would like everything
it's all about inspiration right now
people neglect that so much I think
nowadays is I mean it's obvious it's all
about making a buck and we all want to
make money I want to make money not
gonna lie but I would prefer to do it
the right way I'll make it in producing
art that I feel it's not the best I
could do anybody could sell a record
city make a song about ten in this
monster
all jokes aside you just gotta be catchy
and you know gonna get some bomb post
and when you do it that's not I'm not
knocking anybody for what they do
understand what I want but I prefer to
do what I want to do with my art and how
I want it
viewed and you know perceived I want
people to know that I put my everything
and some art even I put it before myself
not being seen in two years creating you
know not putting up you know any
projects like this is just me being you
know trying to evolve myself maybe you
could talk about you like your name why
you stylized it like that I'm especially
on the pretty flicker and here that's it
on March 2 I felt like with the name rot
Jim is like being named after like Tupac
Shakur or Michael Jordan you know it was
I think those shoes too big to try to
fulfill and I wanted to kind of pioneer
my own legacy you know I wanted to leave
back my own path I didn't want to be
like oh well yeah everybody know about
him cuz he came out and yeah that famous
rappers name and nah man I wanted to
start respectfully I wanted to earn my
name and that was the whole point of
this last album at long last a set
because it's basically I got
abbreviations it's a lot ala and it's
like the return of the goddamn seat
rockin was the garden see and I'm
finally accepting that my name is Rakim
and I'm taking ownership of it and I
just want to make Rakim my mother my
father people Slick Rick Big Daddy Kane
those kind of people I want to make them
proud
at a time when New York hip hop was like
not even being respected yeah how did
you and your boys put this whole thing
together man you as a leader of a
movement like you know they put yourself
on you put a whole movement together
it's because like you know I had a
support system it wasn't just like you
know the whole mob was with this and not
only that man like yams-man you know
anything I ever wanted to do he was
super supportive you know he got it he
got my vision I think we was just a
bunch of young visionaries that happened
to get together and that only happens
every once in a few that doesn't always
happen often
everybody has a eclectic vision
individual vision of their own you know
all together with Colette everybody knew
each other's strengths and exactly and
weaknesses and stuff so it would really
helped and I feel like one when we came
in I was our concern wasn't being a
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] out in New York
or being the most successful letter that
we just was on just doing our own thing
and I think that's what helped because
we wasn't trying to do what everybody
else was doing and that I was still
doing our own thing we're gonna give
people with new lifestyle to adapt so
you get what I'm saying cuz times change
I gave all my staff four years ago here
we are again at long last you know I
know like 2014 like you you've been on
the record as saying yams in interview
with double-xl when saying how you know
2014 was a rough year in culture and you
guys weren't really that inspired and
then you actually had tweeted out that
you thought it was a terrible year in
music culture and unity and that 2015 is
the rebirth of it all on the year of the
underdogs mark my words do y'all agree
with me on that
this year alone would we this is the
fourth month right mm-hmm
we already have releases from some of
the greatest artists and hip hop alone
like I'm on the internet and I'm hearing
these little kids that's coming out and
he snick is this fresh like they way
better than all these [ __ ] that's in a
game like man it's all about the youth
it's all about tomorrow and I don't
think just because a person has a
million dollars in a bank account that
that makes them a credible artist or not
you know I'm listening to people you
know who still live at a mother's house
and still trying to figure it out as
long as you got some jiggy to say I'm a
listen and if you got a dope visual to
go with it I'm bought well I'm a kid to
myself so part of my language but you
know real life stuff with you guys you
know and uh I hope that you could
respect that and I hope you could feel
that you know because we're all real
people at the end of the day you know
when all the lights are off or real
people you got to be who you are you
know and uh I'm quite sure you guys
notice already right you're geniuses
right
yeah but let me get back to the topic at
hand I'm going all over the place did I
say I was happy to be here I feel like
we're at the day and age where well I
know we had a day and age where these
companies the radio the media these
markets man it's getting really getting
scary for them because a lot of
independent independent companies or
just personalities are coming and doing
it the right way like people like
Spotify you know coming and taking
something like streaming the YouTube and
Vimeo were places that you would go to
go see videos all day you didn't think
not enough that they found out how to
monetize at the streaming service and
now that's they're bigger than the
labels so we're looking at iTunes and
Spotify and all these other guys those
are going to be the biggest record
labels within the next two years you
know and people are not they're not
seeing I will what I noticed is as a
rapper or as the artist with the
internet I can make my own label you can
you could do it yourself I mean
obviously you know you can't you might
not have the money that those companies
have but trust me there's a way and I
think I think it's obvious to them I
think it's obvious to the world that
stuff like radio stuff like you know the
old marketing formulas they don't apply
to my generation man our attention span
these kids nowadays man you gotta
entertain them really quick or they
gonna click to something else man you
know I mean I can admit it
I'll get online and I start you know
looking at ads and whatever and I'm just
closing out things out I really if it
doesn't spark my interest if it's not
funny if it's not ignorant half the time
I won't watch it you know and that's
just you if it's not something that's
entertaining and uh you know dealing
with a regular label and being an artist
at this day and age and is doing things
from an independent standpoint I get to
see
both sides of the grass and you know I
get to see the politics within it and in
the flaws you know and uh I think as far
as people like you guys geniuses and my
generation to come I'm more scared of
you guys because you guys are way more
advanced you know and the kids after
you're gonna be twice as advanced as you
guys are man you know how like they
always used to say like respect your
elders and it's like the other way
around now man like the tables have
turned man these kids are geniuses man
and you know that's really I'm you know
that's what I'm basically up here trying
to articulate you know without feeling
like I'm talking to myself
but yeah when I started a set part of me
I didn't start ASAP I joined in 2007 it
was a crew from Harlem if you guys don't
know about it that's my crew and uh it
was a bunch of just teenage kids that
just wanted to do teenage things you
know I don't think I have to specify at
this point right and uh basically you
know that leads to nothing because you
just you know wake up and before you
know you just spent all summer having
fun you don't have anything accomplished
now I have any money you don't have a
job nothing right I looked around and I
just said man we got to do something
about this we need to utilize each other
because together we're all the
collective now is the obvious I think
the main part in our day and age is just
identifying and stating the obvious like
common sense you'd be surprised how many
people like it you know and um I used my
common sense and it led to me trying to
use the internet as an outlet to market
myself to get my brand out there because
nowadays if it hung up by show of hands
how many people are aspiring artists out
there rather be music you know painting
no really thank you we got one artist I
know it's more than that
music dance theater cinematography it's
art you know the arts that's it
so I'm in a room for the geniuses right
now you guys are telling me that you
these are the only artistic people don't
be shy came to talk the other day what's
up how many people watched show of hands
have a passion for art don't be ashamed
it doesn't mean you're a loser you're
gonna be like Basquiat and do heroin
it's ok alright I think we're finally
getting to know one another today you
know what I will say is I'm quite sure
everything that I'm saying you guys are
so advanced you know already and it is
I'm just thinking obvious it's common
sense you know for those of you who are
trying to be artists or who have it in
them there's just so many different the
ways that you would market a brand as
far as a company and incorporation
there's the same way you have the
markets yourself these days because a
brand is no longer like just a company
it could be an individual for instance
if a set rocky goes out and you know
which this would never happen but shoots
a hundred people who would mess up my
brand I didn't just one person no but I
mean it's common sense right I'm just
breaking it down to the basics for y'all
right now you know but it's the truth
it would mess up my brand as a person
what about my friends who had nothing to
do with it what about my you know that's
that's just that's that's what I mean by
that when I tell you guys that we're all
a brand and um I came here today to talk
about that and fashion just like in hip
hop you can't only set the bar you also
have to raise it here's a look at some
fashion do's and don'ts do be unique in
independent with your styling choices
don't wear NFL jersey with your name in
the back of it unless you're willing to
take a hit for that team
do when it comes to fashion break out
the box
take a risk you don't literally wear a
box you have a hairstyle that
complements your overall style
don't don't shave your sideburns above
your ears you look like a damn narc for
summer you dress casually when a
situation calls for it don't dress like
you're golfing even when you're golfing
don't push me Bob now's not the time I
sort of got a hater we go berserk dude
just like writing lyrics sometimes just
keep it simple don't over accessorize as
people are gonna end up pity in the pool
baby suck adapter key I pity the fool do
where the Canadian tuxedo
no don't wear the Canadian sexy look
pepper
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Chad Britton
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did a SAP
Rockies say that had the biggest impact
on you what are you gonna take from his
message and immediately apply to your
life for business somehow leave it down
in the comments below and I'm gonna join
in the discussion I also want to give a
quick chat at the Tina Chang Tina thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book your one word and making that fun
YouTube video around it as well I really
really really appreciate the support
this is my second piece of artwork it
means the baby ARDS your one word in
Chinese so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
based on a movement that you got started
after yams passed called tweet like yeah
sweet like games and basically is taking
his funniest quotes and just you know
showcasing them I think I think his his
state of mind just his personality
it was never broadcasted or just people
didn't know you would have to be a true
cult following really while he was alive
to understand you know yams you know Lou
Newport but yeah I think that it I think
that he's gone it's like one of those
things it's like awareness and it's just
spreading his importance in hip hop and
how he is contribution to hip hop people
who starting to see his influence and
it's not just a side rocky like it's not
just me influencing people and setting
transits like my crews tight but most of
all like my best friend man he had ill
vision and I think you know a lot of
people miss and love him for that
because you know not only just music and
stuff people he was a personal guy with
a lot of people I didn't even know you
know exactly have a personal
relationship so I think that's kind of
tight it's important I'm just trying to
spread that peace in love amongst
hip-hop amongst the brothers and sisters
men you know say